احتفالات المحترفين في السعوديه تتصدر
المنصات زي السعودي وعرضه كمان ونجمه
الصفقه منى حسين وروان مهدي ضيف فتاه
تفاعلكم ونحس سلالم الطائرات يلاحق بايدن
ويطيح ثاني اهلا من جديد
[موسيقى]
امس احتفل السعوديين بيوم التاسيس اللي
شفنا خلاله فعاليات وعروض فنيه وثقافيه
وشعبيه شملت كل المناطق الاحتفالات
التنوعات وكان نجمها كلها الزيت التقليدي
السعودي فشفنا ازياء مختلف المناطق في
الشوارع والفعاليات مو بس المواطنين طبعا
على فكره حتى المقيمين والزوار كمان وطبعا
من ضمنهم نجوم وعلى راسهم كريستيانو
رونالدو اللي هنا السعوديه بيوم التاسيس
ونشر فيديو لمشاركته في الاحتفالات كمان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
امور رونالدو بس نادي الاتحاد كمان شارك
صور لمدربوا لاعبين المحترفين بالزيت
السعودي احتفالا بيوم التاسيس
[موسيقى]
طرح على نتفليكس 8 فبراير المسلسل الكويتي
الصفقه اولي من بدايه عرضهم حقق نجاح كبير
وتفاعل جميل من الجمهور المتابع للمسلسل
المسلسل من وقت طرحه متصدر قوائم الاكثر
مشاهده خليجيا وعربيا فهو في المركز الاول
من ضمن المسلسلات الاكثر مشاهده في الكويت
من اسبوعين لليوم وكمان متصدر المركز
الاول على نتفليكس السعوديه من وقت طرحه
ومن ضمن المراكز الثلاث الاولى ضمن الاكثر
مشاهده في الامارات
مطلقه
ولا قاعده سنه ما اشتغلت
[موسيقى]
اني افتكر على نفسي
انا اشتغل في بورصه الكويت
هذا مكتبك والله الصراحه انا اللي اشترت
اني اكون معاكم
انا ما اشوف انه في بنات غير نحن
[موسيقى]
اهلا ساره النور نورك
شكلكم كذا ماني متعود عليكم بهذا الشكل
الشكل اللي رجعتوا فيه للحياه العصريه
متعوده عليكم بالشكل لوك الثمانينات خلينا
نبتدي معك يا روان خلينا نبتدي بروان كيف
كانت هذه التجربه
والله التجربه هذه نفس ما قلت بالنسبه لي
يعني هي الخطوه الاولى نحو تحقيق الحلم
يعني
لكل لي انا كفنانه ولنا كلنا والخطوه يعني
من معايير الانتاجيه يعني
الخطوه الاولى يعني بدايه الحلم الحقيقي
اللي انا كنت اطمح له من البدايه
منى يمكن كثير ناس انصدموا ان القصه مبنيه
على احداث حقيقيه
كيف تعاملتي مع هذا الموضوع
صراحه احنا كنا دائما نبحث عن نص وورق
ثقيل وعميق
ووجود قصه حقيقيه نقدر ننفذها هذه كانت
احد احلامنا الصغيره
لانه فعلا احنا عندنا بطلات وعندنا شخصيات
مهمه جدا عاشوا في حقب كثيره لازم نسلط
عليهم الضوء يعني يحق لهم ان احنا نصلي
عليهم الضوء وبالذات لما يكونون من
الشخصيات الفعاله واللي اثبته قوه المراه
وجودها وثقافتها الثقبه القديمه وحتى
ليومنا هذا يعني انتم الاثنين ما شاء الله
عليكم نجمات وامراتين يعني عاملتين في
الوسط وبرضو لا زال الوسط الفني مسيطر
عليك كثير الرجال خصوصا في مواقع القرار
اذا ابتديت معاكي يا روان والسؤال لكم
انتم الاثنين لكن اذا قلت لك انه من وقت
اللي فيه الاحداث المسلسل للان ايش حسي في
تغيرات او ما حسيتي في تغيرات كثير
لا اكيد في تغيرات كثير بس انا ما عرفت
يعني مثلا كدراسه هو يعني طبيعي يعني
تغييرات كثيره لكن انا احس يعني الناس من
جيل الثمانينات او من تسعينات او حتى اول
الالفين كانوا شايفين هذا التغير جاي يعني
وكان الناس كانت قاتل ونفس ما قالت منها
ان احنا يعني
حتى في كل مكان في العالم كل ممثل ومخرج
الى شيء سبايرد من احداث حقيقيه ينفذه
لانه
يعطي فنيه اكثر بحكم انه عنده يكون تفاصيل
ومعلومات اكثر
اللي اشوفه ان احنا اليوم المراه يعني
صارت
يعني تقدر يعني صار لها حق في التصويت بس
بالتصويت بعد في الترشح يعني
المناصب السياسيه الاداريه الفنيه يعني
الان انا ارى النساء في كل مكان في كل
المجالات دائما في امثله واضحه للمراه
القائده الناجحه يعني ايه هذا واضح حقيقه
واصبح يعني امر طبيعي هو يعني حتى انه
كاتبه العمل ناديه مهديته لكل امراه عامله
وكافحت وما الى ذلك منى ايش تحسي فيه فرق
او تغيير
والله شوفي القصه
تمثل المراه نفس ما قالت روان في كل وقت
وكل زمان ويمكن في كل دوله بعد اذا كانت
دول عربيه او دول غربيه احنا كان هدفنا
الوحيد انه نبي المساواه نبي
نثبت ان المراه هي لا تقل اهميه عن وجود
الرجل في مجتمعنا فهي نصفه الثاني المكمل
وهذا كان اساس القصه ان هذول المراتين حتى
لو كانوا امه في وقت اللي هو حقبه هذه
كانت جدا غنيه ثقافيا وسياسيا وحتى فنيا
لا تقل اهميه عن الوقت الحالي ولكن احنا
كنا نبي نوري الجمهور او نقنعه بقصه
حقيقيه انه المراه موجوده المراه موجوده
ومو بس الحين من قبل الحين هم هي موجوده
ولكن
شوي عليها صعوبات في كثره
يعني خلينا نقول انك ترى والحريم الاذكياء
والحريم الفعاله الحريم اللي يشتغلون صارت
المراه تنزل الحين العمل لحالها حال الرجل
يمكن يتنا فتره ما كانت المراه عامله كانت
اغلبها ست بيت ممكن يعني لو حتى ست البيت
طبعا يعني برضو ممكن تكون يعني وظيفه هي
تعتبر صراحه يعني وظيفه كامله يعني
وراكب مثقفه يعني انا ضد اي امراه حتى لو
هي كانت ربت بيت انها تكون
بشكل عام
في وراكي
على خلي بالك من زوزو يعني طيب
روان المراه
نعملي فكرتك
المراه في جميع الازمنه تتوالى نجاحاتها
وهذا اللي احنا كلنا نطمح له خلال واحده
من اكثر النقاط اللي الناس علقوا عليها
وحتى انا علقت لكم اول ما ظهرتوا موضوع
الملابس والمكياج والاشياء هذا كله روان
اكيد لاحظتي انه الناس جالسه تنشر
الاطلالات اللي طلعتي فيها والكلام هذا
كله كيف كانت التعامل مع هذا الموضوع
والحرص انه لازم تكونوا دقيقين في هذه
المرحله
بصراحه هذه كانت مسؤوليه الاطراف المنتجه
بالنسبه لي واحده من الناس اللي يعني
عندنا في الوسط الدرامي الكويتي طور
العمليه يعني ساعدنا ان احنا نرفع
وطبعا بوجود
يعني
وشركه انتاج مسؤوله وحريصه واعيه مع بعض
فكان بالنسبه لنا موضوع ايزي يعني هم اللي
الموضوع كامل بالنسبه لهم متعب احنا
كنانين نسوي ونختار مع بعض نتكلم
الشخصيه وكانت دلال بالضبط يعني
حتى الحاله وانا وين الحين فريده وهذه اي
حلقه وليش انا بلبسك هاللون ولا هالطول
ولا يعني كانت يعني تفاصيل شغلوا عليها مو
عاديه وهذا طبعا الواجب الفني هذا
بالنهايه وامه اتقنوه وخلو الموضوع علينا
سهل بس انا دلوعه انا كنت وايد اتضايق ان
انا وايد اطول اقعد على كرسي الميك اب
والشعر وما احب الميك اب بالوايد
كنت وايد اتعب البنات الميك اب والشاعر
معي بس حرام بس كنت احس يعني روان على
الاقل اوكي صح عندك تسريحه المعوجه كانت
والعجيبه وكذا بس احس منى حظها في الميك
اب هو اللي كان اشنع يعني كنت تطلعي
الان ما حد يستخدمها اخضر وازرق كله
فعلا احنا ترى حتى
طلبناهم كلهم اون لاين من امريكا لان في
الوان معينه كنا نحتاجها حق الشخصيه
والناس ما قالت دلال احنا ما تعبنا
بالتجهيز كثر ما الفريق هو حرام اللي تعب
وجهز ورسم انه طبعا زي ما قالت روان ودلال
هي المسؤوله كانت عن الاطلالات وطبعا
الشركه المنتجه على راسهم طبعا الاستاذ
عبد الله ابو شهري كفريق او هم اشتغلوا
على التفاصيل هذه وشكل الشخصيه احنا كنا
مركزين وايد انا وروان اكثر على الاداء
والحاله والداينامكس اللي بين الشخصيتين
بالذات ان احنا ما كنا نعرف بعض انا وروان
فنيا عدل ما اشتغلنا مع بعض مباشره كان
هذا اول عمل نكون يعني مع بعض حيل فالحمد
لله من من البدايه من اول ما بلشنا
البروبات مع الكوتش انا وروان على طول
اندمجنا يعني
انصدمتي لما كنت تشوفي نفسك
بالايشد الازرق وكده
صراحه يعني شوفي اقول لك شغله انا بعد
عندي مشكله في الميك اب وفي الالوان
وتسريحات الشعر وكذا وكنت ساعات اقول
معقوله كانوا يحطون الالوان يعني
دلوقتي يعدي علينا بلا ما اسالكم عن بعض
الانتقادات اللي كمان جات للعمل كمان عمل
بعض الناس قالوا انكم تكلمتوا بطريقه
بطريقه عصرنا الان انه مثلا تسرق الاضواء
هذا التعبير ما كان موجود ستيل ديلايت
مثلا ولا كده ما كانت هذه الاشياء موجوده
مثلا
تفاصيل من هذا النوع ونقطه ثانيه نقطه
التدخين الكثير انه النساء في الكويت اكيد
ما كانوا بيدقنوا كثير في هذه العقبه
اولا الكلام الادله
المصطلحات هذه كوزي والاستين في مجتمعات
في عوائل معينه كانت دائما يدرسون مدارس
اجنبيه وحتى بره ابنائهم هذه كانت موجوده
بس كانت يعني
حسب كل عائله يعني فاحنا هذا وهذا كان
مكتوب نص يعني قصه حياه اصلا ناديه يعني
فهذه يعني كانت موجوده اصلا جود بمدرسه
البريطانيه فريده بالهيستوري بالمدرسه
بريطانيه على فكره جامعه بلندن فاذا ما
قدرت جامعه بلندن اهلها ما قبلوا ففي
تفاصيلك يعني لكن التوم انا بالنسبه لي
فريده كنت احط لها تون مال شوي الكويتين
يعني هذا ما ذاك الوقت اللي اللي بين
القديم والعصري اللي
هني اللعب كان بالنسبه لي فريده ومنى
التدخين موضوع التدخين بما انك دخنتي اكثر
من روان في المسلسل
بدايه انا احترم وجهات النظري معه واللي
ضد طبعا الجمهور يحق له انه هو ينتقد او
يحق له انه يعجب سالفه التدخين في حد ذاته
ترى هي مشاهد محصوره في اماكن معينه لو لو
ندخل بديتيلز مالها يعني يمكن الناس تفهم
من خلالكم ان احنا دخلنا في اوقات اول شيء
نكون احنا الاثنين مع بعض في حاله حاله
الصحبه او حاله الذكريات القديمه بين
منيره وفريده كذلك لما دشت فريده البورصه
صار عندنا مكان برايفت اللي اللي مطلع فيه
حركتنا اللي نشتكي لبعض اللي نتهاوش احنا
الاثنين
اماكن التدخين كانت اماكن تخصي الشخصيتين
لهذا ما هذا ماله شغل بانه الحريم
الكويتيات يدخنون ولا لا احنا حطيناها
لانه كنا سبب يطلعون في مشاعرهم الحقيقيه
بينهم بين بعض او
في ماضيهم اللي امه لما اعطتها قالت لها
يلا خلنا نتذكر او انت تطلقتي او ففي
اماكن هي اللي استخدمنا فيها سجاير بالعكس
ما ما حطيناها في اماكن عامه ولا جراه ولا
ان اهانه لاي شيء بالعكس فنعم او لا في
جزء ثاني
يا رب الله يسمع منك
نتمنى الله اعلم يلا احنا بنشكركم جدا على
هذه الاطلاله معنا اليوم والحقيقه انا
يعني يعني بس من عندي رايي الشخصي بهرتوني
بالاداء يا بنات رائع رائع رائع رائع كان
ادائكم مستوى عالي جدا صراحه كان معانا
كانون نجمتين عمل طبعا الصفقه روان مهدي
ومنى حسين شكرا لكم
اهلا من جديد امس في حلقتنا تكلمنا عن
حقيقه مقطع فيديو متداول لاحد يسقط من على
درجه الطائره الرئاسيه الامريكيه في مطار
وورسو والناس فكرت انه سقط الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن لكن في اللحظه الاخيره
طلعت موظفه في البيت الابيض تعثرت وسقطت
وما تم الكشف عن هويتها خلوني اذكركم
بالمقطع
او عرضنا نحن عليكم الان طيب خلينا اوريكم
هذا المقطع الثاني اللي هو يبدو انه الناس
فعلا فكرت او انه الناس اللي فكرت انه في
الفيديو الاول بايدن طاح لا هذولي كانوا
بيفاولوا على الرئيس الامريكي لانه بايدن
وهو بيغادر وورس وامس وطالع درجه طياره صح
هذه مو اول مره يطيح على درج طياره
حلقه اليوم وحلقه امس كمان رح ننهي اليوم
حلقتنا باحتفالات يوم التاسيس مجموعه ام
بي سي شاركت في الاحتفالات بطرح اغنيه من
انتاجها وغناء النجم ماجد المهندس بعنوان
1727 الاغنيه من كلمات خالد المريخي
والحان محمد مدلو وعنوانها يشير لدى تاريخ
تاسيس الدوله السعوديه بالسلط الضوء في
كلماتها والكليب على تاريخ المملكه الراسخ
الممتد اكثر من ثلاثه قرون انا اترككم مع
مقطع من الاغنيه واعود القاكم الاحد ان
شاء الله في امان الله
يا نخله من دون الاحاد السفن عرقك بلا
رضوان
يحرسك ربي السعودي
امين يا ام المعزه والوفاء والكرام
نخله من دونها حاد سيفين عرقك بالارض
[موسيقى]
يا ام المعزه والوفاء والكرامه
يما المعزه والوفاء والكرم
ات كل ما كبرتي يا بلادي تزيني
وانت كبيره اصلا من البدايه
[موسيقى]